[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
entrepreneuriales du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines nous sommes
aujourd'hui à promo paul la pépinière
d'entreprises historique de saint
quentin en yvelines implantée à montigny
le bretonneux
cette structure accueille 130
entreprises dont 76 société qui viennent
au quotidien dans la structure plusieurs
secteurs d'activité sont représentés
comme le bâtiment le service à la
personne l'événementiel les nouvelles
technologies ou encore l'ingénierie nous
irons rencontrer deux dirigeants
d'entreprises qui viennent de
s'installer sur le site de promo paul
c'est au programme de ce 33e numéro du
sky échos l'événement dédié à
l'innovation tech'innove se déroulera le
23 mars prochain à paris un concours
organisé par saint quentin en yvelines
qui donne l'occasion à des start-up d'y
participer gratuitement les 130
entreprises iae promo cole ont fait
preuve de résilience durant la crise
sanitaire bilan est des reprises
économiques
nous faisons le point sur la situation
économique globale de la pépinière puis
de nouvelles entreprises ont rejoint
promo paul en 2021 c'est le cas de
milady production et sopra tech
rencontre dans cette édition
[Musique]
pour commencer cette émission nous
allons faire un focus sur la vie à promo
paul durant la crise sanitaire et les
conséquences de la pandémie sur les
entreprises pour en parler nous sommes
avec le directeur général de promo paul
lotman nasri ou bonjour
bonjour alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment les entreprises ont
vécu cette crise sanitaire
cette fille sanitaire a forcément été un
moment difficile pour beaucoup d'entre
elles vous savez que la promo paul on
héberge eu beaucoup de petites
structures qui ont été très directement
impactés dans leur carnet d'adressés par
l'impact de la crise sanitaire les
confinements successifs et est
globalement d'une baisse très forte de
leur activité et donc il ya tout de
suite eu une grande inquiétude notamment
2020 aujourd'hui je dirais qu'il ya
davantage de visibilité pour elle
construit on peut plutôt être rassurés
mais c'est parce que les pouvoirs
publics aussi ont su être aux côtés de
ces entreprises et je crois que beaucoup
sont satisfaites de cette visibilité qui
a pu leur être données au moment où les
choses étaient les plus difficiles et
les plus confuse alors quelles ont été
les conséquences de la pandémie sur les
entreprises de promo paul alors pour un
certain nombre d'entreprises après apple
nous avons directement proposées à ce
qu'il puisse y avoir des allègements de
loyer le temps que l'activité puisse
reprendre on l'a fait de manière
générale en avril 2020 ou du premier
confinement nous avons offert un mois de
loyer dispenser les entreprises
installées d'un mois de loyer ça
représente une enveloppe de près de
90000 euros q et impulser venir soulager
la trésorerie des entreprises installées
dans la structure
mais plus généralement il y aura eu des
circonstances plus difficile pour un
certain nombre d'entreprises ses invités
à se rapprocher de nous s'il y avait des
difficultés de trésorerie et on a pu
concéder des allègements de loyer le
temps que l'activité se redresse et
aujourd'hui on a quasiment plus de
structures qui sont dans cette situation
là quelques petits cas encore qui
nécessite une vigilance particulière
mais dans l'ensemble la quasi totalité
des entreprises semblent avoir retrouvé
des niveaux d'activité
convenable vous des chiffres d'ailleurs
à nous donner un
oui en 2020 on va bien sûr des chiffres
aussi d'occupation de la structure qui
auront pu être légèrement à la baisse
mais comme nous avions aussi une forte
demande et beaucoup de petites surfaces
ça a pu atténuer les effets 2d quelques
baisses qu'on a pu avoir et donc on n'a
pas été très directement impactés par
par par ces difficultés là aujourd'hui
probable un taux d'occupation qui est de
98% donc la pépinière est à nouveau
complètement pleines on a pu descendre
autour de 90% 88% au plus fort de la
crise donc ce n'était pas non plus une
catastrophe mais parce que on a toujours
eu d une forte demande en petit ou
petites surfaces malgré la crise
sanitaire au delà bien sûr des périodes
de confinement et donc on a pu ainsi
bien stabiliser les choses malgré les
dépenses exceptionnelles que ça engendre
et je pense notamment aux dépenses
sanitaires qui était extrêmement
importante qui ronge entrer des coûts
importants pour la structure aujourd'hui
les choses sont bien stabilisé et bien
merci autre magnat ce coup je rappelle
que vous êtes le directeur général de
promo paul merci à vous et le sky échos
se poursuit nous allons aller rencontrer
deux représentants d'entreprises qui se
sont installés à promo paul en 2021
et pour commencer ce tour d'horizon des
nouvelles entreprises qui ont rejoint un
promo paul en 2021 direction milady
production cette société est spécialisée
dans la production audiovisuelle a été
créée en 2009 et aujourd'hui elle est
installée à promo paul
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint jean-louis prignac le
dirigeant de milady production bonjour
bonjour
alors déjà un mot sur votre société dans
un millier de production et une société
de production audiovisuelle et on
travaille sur tout ce qui concerne le
son et l'image vous êtes deux associés
c'est ça absolument alors vous êtes
installé à promo paul depuis octobre
2021 et je crois savoir que c'est à
cause du coded ben oui les locaux dans
lesquels on était avant le coc vides ont
été vendus et on a été obligé de changer
au mois d'octobre c'est un peuple on a
trouvé bon on a trouvé vous étiez ou
avant à guyancourt et pourquoi qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait par rapport au
coût est bien le propriétaire dû vendre
son local parce qu'il avait des
difficultés financières et donc le
nouveau repreneur ne voulait pas de
locataire ça s'est fait très rapidement
avec chrome os palm a alors non ça c'est
pas faire rapidement ça a été un peu
long puisqu'on les a contactés en mai
et nous il fallait qu'on statue sur
notre situation aussi économique parce
que c'était une vraie problématique donc
ça a mis trois à quatre mois justement
comment ça s'est passé comment vous avez
traversé la crise sanitaire nous on a eu
la chance de la traversée à peu près
bien puisqu'on on a signé des contrats à
chaque fois en début d'année pour la
totalité de l'année sur des produits
qu'on venait de mettre en place ce qui
était des produits qui ne sollicitait
pas les équipes techniques en tournage
donc on a fait beaucoup de motion
graphic beaucoup d'illustrations et ça
nous a permis de passer toute cette
période difficile c'est le digital le
numérique qui vous a sauvé en quelque
sorte oui c'est exactement ça c'est pas
quelque sorte c'est exactement ça va
vous avez contribué à donc à cette
transformation digitale de la société
dit l'ong a causé la crise sanitaire ça
s'est accéléré quoi voilà exactement ça
s'est accéléré mais surtout le nono nos
clients ont vraiment joué le jeu puisque
en faire on devait dissocier la partie
production la partie tournage de la
partie post production est en fait ce
sont eux qui sont chargés de films et de
faire des illustrations avec leur iphone
avec tout ça et nous on s'est chargé de
tout la postproduction et toute la
sonorisation des films ces contrats ont
permis de limiter la casse où vous avez
quand même enregistré un gain en chiffre
d'affaires on a enregistré un gain on a
on a eu un petit plus de 12% la sueur
2020 et 2021 ce qui était tout à fait
inattendu et salaire de continuer sur
toujours sur la même thématique là on
sent qu'on a pris un chemin
créé par le co vide vous avez quand même
des problématiques notamment en termes
de ressources humaines c'est ça oui on a
ça fait depuis qu'on a créé la société
en 2009 on a toujours essayé de
développer sur place un partenariat avec
les écoles avec les chaînes de
télévision et de créer un pôle de
techniciens qui seraient sur place dans
lequel on pourrait épuiser
malheureusement depuis dix ans ça n'a
pas marché on fait on a toujours des
stagiaires mais une fois qu'ils sont
sortis de l'école et ben ils partent
dans le milieu professionnel et on les
revoit plus on les renvoie très peu donc
c'est une vraie problématique on
n'arrive pas à régler d'avoir un pool de
techniciens locaux avec les clients
puissent travailler merci jean luc
rignac bien c'est à vos dirigeants de
milady production est justement vous
parliez de recrutement on va aller tout
de suite voir une entreprise nouvelle de
promo paul qui est engagée dans ce
domaine d'activité
c'est la première agence du groupe
soitec dans les yvelines une agence
spécialisée dans le recrutement pour les
entreprises techniques elle s'est
installée en novembre 2000 21 à promo
paul nous allons tout de suite à leur
rencontre
[Musique]
pour parler de l'installation de sopra
tech à montigny le bretonneux à promo
paul nous sommes avec marie noëlle elian
bonjour bonjour
2 alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
comment ça se passe depuis le lancement
de votre activité ici à
montigny-le-bretonneux en novembre 2000
21 ah bah ça se passe très très bien on
est dans un bassin qui est très
dynamique qui bouge énormément avec de
très beaux clients donc ça se passe
super bon bien puis en plus vous êtes
dans une pépinière d'entreprises donc je
suppose que vous tisser des liens aussi
avec les entreprises qui sont présentes
ici tout à fait donc ça une facilité
justement promo pote qui est déjà
idéalement placé et qui nous permet en
fait de rencontrer plusieurs centres
offrent beaucoup d'entreprises discute
avec établir des relations on va dire de
confiance et aussi beau aussi des
relations avec nos candidats qui sont
disponibles dans le secteur vous êtes
trois collaborateurs ici en quoi
consiste votre activité au quotidien
c'est quoi alors moi je suis chargé de
recrutement je suis une spécialiste mort
à dire des différentes jacques borde que
nous avons puisque nous sommes des
experts dans les domaines dans l'état
sur des profils techniques de
l'industrie et nous utilisons pas mal de
on va dire d'outils très professionnel
et il nous avions aussi un vivier qui
est très conséquent et très solide qui
nous permet de pouvoir des candidats
enfin des profits les besoins de clients
très spécifiques il ya reprise
économique depuis 2000 21s poursuit en
2022 malgré certaines incertitudes des
secteurs activit d'activités aussi qui
ont des besoins énormes en main d'oeuvre
comment vous gérer cette situation
justement dans dans les métiers en
tension comme nous alors nous sommes des
experts dont nous avions des outils qui
sont là pour répondre à ses besoins nous
avions aussi un vivier qui est très
solide comme je le disais tout à l'heure
donc il nous permet de proposer des
candidats qui sont disponibles à
l'instant t pour des besoins à laisse
tenter ea qui permet aussi du coup de
faire valoir notre qualité de travail et
nous avons aussi en perpétuelle du
recrutement qui sont en cours si on doit
faire un bilan depuis novembre on s'est
fait combien de recrutements alors
aujourd'hui on compte une trentaine de
recrutement au sein de sopra tech qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour 2022
alors pour 2022 toujours avoir la même
qualité travail qui je suis sûr restera
qui va évoluer dans tous les cas puisque
on s'améliore de jour en jour et des
pouvoirs nous créer une identité forte
dans le secteur et dans le bassin du 78
merci beaucoup marie noëlle et lyon 6e
je rappelle que vous êtes chargé de
recrutement à sopra tech à
montigny-le-bretonneux et le sky échos
se poursuit dans la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul
[Musique]
c'est une tradition pour les acteurs de
l'innovation le rendez-vous theckly
noble et rassemble chaque année cette
journée de rencontres et de business se
déroulera le 23 mars 2022 au parc floral
de paris dans ce contexte saint quentin
en yvelines organise un concours pour
les startups objectif gagner des places
gratuites pour participer à cet
événement les détails dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
oh
petit à trois critères il faut être une
start up ou une entreprise innovante il
faut être implantées sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines et il faut
avoir un produit une solution à services
innovants
prêts à être commercialisés ou déjà en
phase de commercialisation
[Musique]
comme tous les porteurs pour les
entreprises demandent de participer à ce
concours d'être sélectionné dans une
barque c'est d'avoir de la visibilité
bénéficier de sa visité deuxième intérêt
c'est participer gratuitement à cet
événement c'est plus de 15000 rendez
vous sur cette journée donc c'est une
formidable vitrine est une formidable
opportunité de créer des contacts
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi une émission que vous
pouvez revoir en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile et
on se retrouve bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]